George Orwell was born as Eric Blair in
1903 the name George Orwell his pen name
was something that was invented to be as
English sounding as possible Orwell is a
river that runs through Suffolk and
George is that quintessentially English
name so oh well is kind of a creative
self he is a version of himself that he
puts across in all of his writing in his
essays in his journalism in a way the
character of George Orwell is kind of
similar to how we today curate our
online identity particularly in social
media like most people in his generation
Orwell was fascinated by technology and
what technology could do without ever
having any clear idea of what it
actually practically consisted of just
after the Second World War for example
he was given or bought one of the very
first by rows which had just been
invented and all well thought I think
this was a kind of miraculous invention
Orwell's novel 1984 is full of
technology and what technology can do to
help oppressive systems work their evil
basically the principle controlling
device the telescreen has this
extraordinary ability to monitor people
as they go about their daily lives
and literally spiral almost everything
they do but there were also a few spaces
where these telly screens don't exist in
working-class areas of London for
example in the prole pub if only that
were true in the contemporary world
there's no real escaping from our
interactions with screens on a daily
basis it's almost impossible not to look
at one one thing that's different about
Orwell's most famous book 1984 and the
presence is that in 1984 the state
controls all the media and all the
messaging that citizens interact with in
the present day there's a much more
diverse landscape in terms of how things
report it and the fact that we can all
with smart phones in our pockets type
about what's going on in front of us and
post videos online is an important
distinction to be made this said there
are states who try to suppress people
talking about things online and we see
this all over the world some recent
examples might be in Kashmir where
there's being a media
and in xingyang in china if he were
alive today it's perfectly conceivable
that all well would have been sifting
through social media with the idea of
writing some kind of structural analysis
of how it worked in much the same way
that 78 years before he would write
essays about the kind of magazines that
teenage boys were in their spare time or
well in a way is like the curation of
our digital cells today part of the
character of George Orwell that he
creates is to be a truth teller to tell
it down the line to tell it like it is
or well may have been troubled by the
way in which miss truths and lies and
even innocent mistakes can spread so
quickly on social media out-of-control
technology enables this you know it's
very easy with a smartphone with Twitter
and social media to to sow a seed of
disquiet to seed an untruth into
people's consciousness all well was
obsessed with the idea of future worlds
the shape of things to come
and obviously the part that technology
would play in enabling those worlds to
exist in function thanks for watching
don't forget to subscribe and click the
bail to receive notifications for new
videos see you again soon